what's going on guys welcome to part
three of the my hero academia war arc
review
i want to thank you for your support on
the previous part that video went well
past 3 000 likes so i do really
appreciate it
also last thing just before we start if
you want to win some free merchandise
and also
see my face reveal then stick around to
the end of this video because i'll be
linking to
that video which you need to see but
without further ado
let's get into it the story picks up
with the number one hero
endeavor flying straight towards
tomorrow shagaraki
endeavour unleashes a previously unseen
move called hell's curtain
which surrounds the area in a blanket of
flames with shiguraki trapped in the
center
as this is going on the voice of all for
one intrudes into tomorrow's mind
commanding him to steal one for all we
see that shigaraki is literally on fire
as this is happening
but he continues to stand tall as if
nothing is going on
he then leaps forward towards endeavour
with his hand
outstretched and ready to decay him
however thanks to endeavour's lightning
fast reflexes
he avoids the attack and then maneuvers
himself to punch a garaki down into the
rock below
the number one states that no human
being should have been able to move in
this heat
and that shiguraki must now have a super
regeneration quirk
realizing that the situation is a bit
tough he blocks shigaraki with more
flames
and radios the other heroes asking for
backup from basically anyone who can fly
shiggy's hand emerges out of the fire
and once again he goes to dust endeavour
but is narrowly stopped when his wrist
is grabbed that isn't the end of it
though
as the villain delivers an air cannon
point-blank to endeavour's face
we previously saw afo use air cannon
during the battle at kamino
and it's a pretty impressive quirk to
say the least the attack sends endeavour
flying straight through the rock
and landing on the ground with a large
thud this gives suguraki a moment to
breathe
in which he pockets about six or seven
quirk destroying bullets
and picks up one of the hands of his
family members which i'm sure will be
going back on his face
at some point as he continues to
regenerate he wonders why he still
doesn't feel satisfied despite having
all this new power
endeavour comes in and launches a second
wave of attacks
while shiguraki thinks to himself that
something inside is just urging him to
go
after one for all which he then says out
loud endeavour repeats the phrase in
confusion
which is transmitted via the radio to
all the heroes in the area
this moment was especially hilarious
just because of the expression on deku's
face when he heard one thrall mentioned
on the radio
like this man was not ready at all
because of afo shiguraki now has
ragdoll's search quirk
which i've explained in detail in other
videos he uses this power
to locate one for all in the city below
and thanks to his new super strength
he jets off into the sky just like all
might used to do
endeavor warns everyone on the radio
that shigaraki is on the way
which causes serious panic amongst the
students and heroes alike
whilst the evacuation continues deku has
a long hard thing to himself and makes
the decision to run to a deserted area
so that shigaraki will hopefully follow
him and leave the citizens alone
he knows that shiggy is likely looking
for him given that one floor was heard
over the radio
bakugo then tags along before midoriya
can even say anything
because he came to a similar realization
they then speed away together
as todoroki and the others look on in
complete shock just wondering like what
are they doing
using his search quirk shigaraki notices
that one fraule is now on the move
and if you notice there is another
student following behind deku and bakago
though we'll find out who this is a bit
later midoriya then radios endeavour
and we get this funny scene where deku
asks the number one to let him know
if shiguraki changes his direction to
which endeavor replies
like i've got time for that only to
immediately tell deku in his next breath
that shiggy has altered his course as i
explained
the villain is purely after one for all
so he's going wherever deku is going
as they continue moving to the deserted
area bakugou and midoriya have a brief
heart to heart
where we discover that bakugou wants to
get revenge against shiguraki
for the time he was kidnapped and we
also see that
internally he's feeling a bit insecure
about falling behind deku in their path
to become
the best hero as shigaraki glides
through the air
he combines his air cannon with a new
quirk called radio waves
which fries the communication system
that the heroes were using
we then see this awesome panel of deku
and bakugou coming face to face with the
man himself
as shigaraki outstretches his hand ready
to take one for all
in the words of deku this moment gave
him the same fear of
death that he felt when he was in kamino
and encountered all for one
he foresees both himself and bakago
about to disintegrate at the hands of
shiggy
but is saved the last second by gran
torino who comes in clutch yet again
torino is the only other person at this
battlefield
who knows of one for all and when he
heard it over the radio he went looking
for deku
meanwhile as shiguraki falls back to
earth the dragon hero ryukyu
swoops in to smack him right back
interestingly though
as she made contact the villain
attempted to disintegrate her
but his quirk didn't activate this is
thanks to our boy izawa
who appears out of nowhere with his eyes
firmly focused on the villain
a news helicopter then appears in jakku
to start broadcasting the battle
and we see that back at ua omai is
babysitting eerie and
watching with an extremely concerned
look on his face yeah i'm not sure if
eerie should be watching this the manga
then shows us
the families of the heroes involved just
going on with their daily lives
completely oblivious as to what's going
down
anyway because of ryukyu's attack
shigeraki was sent flying into the air
whilst in his quirkless state
however as you can see from this
expression he's not really worried or
fazed or anything like that
he quickly whips out the phone in his
pocket and orders his army of nomu to
kill
every person they see with the help of
his sidekick
endeavour flies directly towards
shigeraki in the air
and pretty much attempts to kill him
just with an all-out burst of fire
this is unsuccessful though as even
without any quirks
the villain was strong enough to push
himself mostly out of the way
in the words of endeavor a swing of the
arm that shigaraki move around freely in
mid-air
just like somebody else according to dr
garaki
it's not quite on the level of all might
but you know it's pretty damn close
tamara then maneuvers in the air and
pulls up in front of endeavour
before punching him down into ryukyu who
was standing below
we then get perhaps the most
disrespectful panel this manga has ever
seen
as he stands on the body of both heroes
and raises his fists
to kind of mock endeavor for what he did
during the pro hero arc
these are two top 10 heroes you know
you've got the number one
and the number the tenth place hero and
he's standing on top of them like this
is
ridiculous oh yeah and before i forget
to mention it
while all of this is going on manuel has
been using his water quirk
in small doses to kind of just keep
izaba's eyes hydrated
and therefore you know he can last way
longer before he needs to blink again
elsewhere gran torino succeeded in
taking deku and bakago to a more
secluded location
away from the big fight torino is about
to head back and help izawa
who's having trouble walking due to his
leg which was previously broken by a
nomu
despite deku's own desire to help the
professor
gran torino warns him to stay far away
as shigaraki can't even be allowed the
opportunity to steal one for all
he tells the students that shiguraki is
just one man
and if all these pro heroes can't defeat
one person then what's the point of this
hero saturated society
however in the distance we can see a few
shadowy figures start to appear
and as they get closer we start to
realize it's the army of higher nomus
that shigaraki had commanded
to kill everyone according to dr garaki
sugaraki woke these nomu
up when he used the radio waves earlier
so it had two purposes
unlike the other hyenas we've seen these
ones actually hadn't made it to the
testing phase yet
so they can't really think for
themselves but their physical
capabilities are still
just as strong as you'd expect amongst
the chaos
sugaraki lunges straight towards izawa
in what must have been
a terrifying moment for the professor
eraserhead thinks about his students
shinzo included and contemplates how he
can't afford to die
not until they graduate and become
heroes also if he dies there will be no
one to hold back shigeraki's full power
so yeah that's pretty important too
rock clock and gran torino lunge in and
try and hold back this demon
but before they can do that a student
who never listens to instructions gets
in there first
and pushes shigeraki back deku says that
while the other heroes are busy fighting
the nomu
he and bakago need to join the battle to
defeat shigaraki
and save izawa in the process in that
spirit
bakugou delivers his ap machine gun
attack whilst deku wraps shigaraki in
black whip
but the villain easily brushes off both
of them and tells bakago that he's no
longer of interest
which is a reference back to the whole
kidnapping fiasco
endeavour swoops in to save the boys by
punching shiguraki
real hard in the torso but this doesn't
keep him down as the madman
quickly regains his balance the number
one hero reiterates
that shiggy's body is as powerful and
sturdy as all mites
and gran torino refers to it as beyond
human at this point
shiguraki then speeds off towards
midoriya and thinks to himself that he
just needs to scoop up deku
and then run away which i thought was
quite a funny thought process
the voice in his head then reappears and
orders him to acquire one for all
and shiguraki says out loud you will be
mine
little brother this moment was like the
will of all for one
overtaking shiguraki's consciousness
which causes the villain to ponder
how whilst he is grateful to afo he
doesn't actually want to be like him
in his words he doesn't want his
master's voice to be inside his head
and he metaphorically destroys the image
of afo
in his mind stating that he now controls
himself
endeavour launches his famous hell
spider attack which was enough to slice
a building into pieces
but shigaraki effortlessly weaves in
between the flames
on his way to capturing deku gran tovino
tries to intervene
and tells shigaraki to stop trampling
over the memory
of nana shimura to which her grandson
replies
who endeavour then tries another attack
as torino holds on to shigaraki
but the villain grows tired of messing
around and quickly uppercuts torino in
the stomach
before blasting past endeavour as he
flies through the air towards deku
bakugou is hovering above shiguraki and
states that midoriya was just the bait
before pulling the pin out of his
gauntlet and unleashing his most
ferocious attack we've ever seen
with shiguraki's body caught up in the
blast endeavour swoops in to finish him
off
not only is this an awesome panel but it
truly feels like a moment in which the
heroes can claim victory
i mean it's not but you know it feels
like that
the manganese switches back to the
forest as gigantomachia attempts to run
to his master
with the league of villains on his back
interestingly though
debbie has also chosen to take skeptic
with him which i
assume will be relevant later on on the
hero side of things
mount lady is the only pro who compares
to machia in terms of size
and despite her best efforts to try and
hold him back he picks her up by the leg
and throws her away
there are other skirmishes occurring at
the same time including cementos facing
off against getting
but their fight was rudely interrupted
by ed shot fighting redestro
kamui woods has midnight on his back and
uses his quirk to swing around like
tarzan
and hopefully get towards mackie's mouth
so that midnight can release her quirk
and put him to sleep what they don't
know is that the league are on maki is
back
and dabi catches them by surprise with a
serious wave of firepower
kamui woods gets totally fried and while
midnight is still
flying through the air mr compress
throws some heavy debris directly in her
path
this causes her to fall back down to
earth and she looks pretty beaten up at
this point
she uses the last of her strength to
radio momo over the communication system
she informs yaya rosu of the situation
and tells her that gigantomachia must be
put to sleep
because he cannot be stopped by brute
force alone while this conversation is
happening
a group of liberation army soldiers
notice midnight crawling on the ground
and one of them goes in for the kill
midnight thinks to herself that momo
will make a
fine leader someday as the scene then
cuts away
leaving her fate completely unclear yaya
rosu desperately calls out to a teacher
but he has
no reply which is never a good sign the
students wonder what they should do next
and after some intense thinking momo
formulates a plan in her mind
which begins with jiro and shoji using
their quirks to estimate
how far away machia is and how tall he
is
jiro uses her quirk and notices that the
beast has slowed down a little bit
which we see is because kamui woods came
back from the brink
and used his wood to time out lady to
macchia's leg
phase two of momo's plan begins as she
uses her body to produce these
undiluted sedatives one of which would
be enough to put gigantomachia to sleep
if it enters his mouth each student is
given one capsule
whilst minetta momo and mudman each lay
down traps that will hopefully trip
machia up
yaya rosu drops some explosives into the
ground whilst mudman makes the earth
pretty soft
so that her dynamite can then sink lower
meanwhile with minetta
he attaches some rope to his sticky
balls which will also be very useful in
a second
as planned machia trips up on the soft
ground
and falls face first into even more soft
ground
he tries to get back up but moneta's
balls are stuck to his chin
which means that other students like
sato and kendo they can pull on the rope
to try and stop him from getting back up
ibarra from class 1b wraps her thorns
around his neck
and all the students are chipping in in
one way or another
for example aoyama is going all out with
the lasers
and denki tries to electrocute the
league of villains but is seriously
injured by mr compress
before he can do that invisible girl and
a bunch of others
attempt to throw sedatives into makia's
mouth but the big guy exhales
pushing back most of the students with
his insane breath
daby follows this up with a wall of
flames that rapidly spreads through the
forest
and prevents those who are blown away
from getting closer
however mina activates her fireproof
acid man armor
and emerges from the fire with the
sedative in her hand
ready to throw mount lady gets up and
uses all of her strength
to grab gigantomachia by the draw and
open his mouth
makia gets angry because all he wants to
do is take the shortest route to
shigaraki
but naturally these heroes are now
making that a bit difficult
ashido hesitates because she recognizes
this voice
and realizes that he is the same
creature she encountered way back in
middle school
fear begins to consume her as the
sedative slips out of her hand
machia then grabs mount lady by the head
and throws her away for the second time
this arc
with his left hand falling straight down
towards mina
and it's about to crusher in the process
luckily though
our unbreakable boy kirishima dives
straight into dabi's flames
and pulled through at the last moment to
push mina out the way
in the process he grabs her capsule
which means he now has two
and tetsutetsu appears bringing her to
safety
gigantomachia finally stands up and he
shakes off all the pro heroes who are
starting to climb on his body
he then holds the league of villain
members in his hands and puts them back
on his back
telling his comrades to hold tight
unknown to him though
there is one hero by the name of red
riot who has been valiantly climbing up
his arm the whole time
kiroshima comes face to face with the
big guy and throws his capsule
only for it to be instantly shattered by
toga who threw her knife
he thinks to himself that thanks to
mina's chivalrous spirit
he now gets a second chance to throw her
capsule into gigantomachia's mouth
which he promptly does in this epic
moment that will
100 give us goosebumps when it's
animated
makia goes to crush kirishima completely
unaware of what he's just eaten
but he's distracted when he starts
receiving fire from these cannons which
momo created
setsuna from class 1b then swoops in to
save
an exhausted red riot as the
professional heroes press forward
to take down giganto makia in the words
of yayarozu
the more makia moves around the faster
the drug should work
so that's the job of the pro heroes now
just getting him moving
weirdly though maki's draw then slides
upwards to cover
his eyes which is something we've never
seen happen before
and as of making this video it's
currently unexplained why this happens
the scene then goes back to jakku with
endeavour standing above shigaraki
telling him that it's over shigaraki has
been seriously hurt by the last attack
and without his supreme generation he's
struggling to breathe
the number one hero says that shiguraki
can never bring down hero society
because his destruction is hollow and
it's not supported
by any ideals that said the villain
replies by repeating something that he
heard from his father
when he was young which is that heroes
hurt their own families
just to help strangers this statement is
very applicable to endeavour
who of course brought his wife to the
brink of insanity not to mention gave a
terrible childhood
to virtually all of his children shiggy
begins to stand up
and says that whilst heroes pretend to
be society's guardians
in reality they ignore people that they
can't protect
with the scene then flashing back to a
young tenko shimura
wandering alone in the streets of japan
he goes on to elaborate
that hero society is rotten from the
core and that people have become so
dependent on heroes that they neglect to
do the right thing
for themselves this was implied by the
flashback that you can see on screen
in which an old lady sees a young tenko
but decides not to do anything because
she assumes
a hero or the police will deal with it
according to shigaraki
the system has always rejected him and
so now he's rejecting it back
which is the reason he took the power of
all for one in his words
he doesn't care if the heroes understand
him or not because this difference in
understanding is what makes them heroes
and villains
and that my friends is the end of part 3
of this war arc review
if you'd like to see my face reveal and
also how you can win some free
merchandise
then click on the video on screen and in
the description which will take you to
that face reveal
as always thank you for watching and
until the next one
peace out